today on the mat wall show Democrats
doubled down on their abortion messaging
heading into the midterms this week
they've offered pro-abortion propaganda
that ranges from unintentionally
hilarious to incredibly horrific also
Elon Musk begins to call the herd over
at Twitter early voting is already
causing confusion and problems a country
star gets in trouble for publicly
associating with Ron DeSantis and the
media worries that the World Series
might be racist because there aren't
enough U.S born black players an oddly
specific complaint we'll talk about all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
criminals comb through the dark web for
stolen items they're looking for your
pii your personal identifiable
information pii includes your full name
your social security number your
driver's license bank account numbers
passport number phone number email
address this is all things they're
looking for and oftentimes they're able
to find that's why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
your personal information gets exposed
so often that it's dangerously easy for
cyber criminals to steal your identity
protecting your identity can be easy
though with LifeLock by Norton LifeLock
detects and alerts you to potential
identity threats that you may not spot
on your own like loans taken out in your
name or crimes committed by thieves
pretending to be you if you do become a
victim of identity threat uh theft that
is a dedicated us-based restoration
specialist will fix it for you and they
will work with you nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
LifeLock by Norton join now and Save 25
percent off your first year at
lifelock.com Walsh that's lifelock.com
Walsh for 25 off
after the Red Wave washes over us on
Tuesday the Democrats will of course
respond by refusing to look inward or
engage in anything like introspection
they will Lament The Death of democracy
they'll accuse Republicans of cheating
Even after spending years claiming that
it's an attack on Democracy to accuse
your opponent of cheating they will
blame the American people they'll blame
racism homophobia transphobia
Arachnophobia all the phobias they'll
say and do many things but one thing
they will not do is spend any time
trying to actually figure out why they
lost and lost so badly if they did they
would say that one of the most
catastrophic mistakes was to make
abortion a central part of their
campaign message they assumed that
voters would be motivated you know by
the overturning of Roe they assumed
Americans would flock to the polls to
defend the right to kill babies they
assumed that most Americans are as
avidly supportive of baby murder as they
are
and they assumed wrongly
but this is the horse they rode in on
and they're going to take it all the way
to the Finish Line regardless in the
final days before the election every
Democratic apparatus is leaning into the
pro-abortion message in ways that range
from unintentionally hilarious to
unbelievably heinous so we'll kind of
ease into this and we'll start with the
hilarious first so over on NBC
the medical drama New Amsterdam which is
a show that apparently exists aired an
episode this week revolving around
um abortion and the overturning of Roe
the daily wire reports quote
the recent episode maybe tomorrow
explores a world with restricted access
to abortion showrunners spoke with TV
line about their motivations and aims
for the episode which had leftist fans
applauding and conservatives swearing
that they're done with the series
forever the episode begins with a
montage showing Hospital staff realizing
Roe v Wade had been overturned which was
presented as a catastrophic event
each character then dealt with the
aftermath in their own way Dr Lauren
Bloom uh played by Janet Montgomery
admits that she had an abortion in the
past which was not a big deal quote
unquote one doctor punched a protester
outside the hospital and New Amsterdam
staffers panic because he's gay and
they're concerned about the Court's
outlawing same-sex marriage at various
points in the episode Max inquires about
opening an abortion clinic on a military
base and setting up a floating Clinic to
circumvent new laws quote these kinds of
issues both in our country in the
healthcare industry is why I wrote the
show to begin with it's why I created
New Amsterdam according to David
Schoener the showrunner which she said
to TV line and interview as depressing
and horrifying as it was the show was
made to tackle these issues and so we
all put in everything we had into this
episode
yes they put everything they had into it
unfortunately that that means that they
didn't put any you know intelligence or
subtlety or wit into it because they
didn't have any uh to begin with which
explains the opening scene as mentioned
in the daily wire article okay it's the
the Montage opening scene and it is it
is honestly
one of the greatest scenes of
unintentional comedy to ever air on
television I mean the whole thing plays
like a parody and when I first saw this
I had to I had to watch it all the way
through and I'm and I'm I'm waiting for
the punch line and it never came
because this is meant to be taken
seriously and you really just have to
see it to appreciate it so let's watch a
little bit of this together
okay so he's reading the news about Roe
v Wade being overturned
he's tearful
and he's looking at his daughter
that young child will never be able to
kill a child and he's that that
he's distraught by that by that
possibility
and it drops the phone he can't even
look at the phone he drops into
disgusting
then we've got the people standing
around the street and they're just
they're dumbfounded because Roe Vue was
ever turned shell-shocked and she drops
she drops the cup they do the dramatic
cup drop
which has been a cliche since like 1995
by the way
and look at all these people walking
down the street every single one of them
I can't believe it
I can't believe they can't kill babies
anymore
you know this is New York and they can
still kill babies so
maybe someone could tell them that make
them feel better
oh and there's another father
[Music]
he's in tears
he's a father is in tears because he's
thinking about uh you know that his
daughter will never be able to kill his
grandchildren and that actually makes
him cry
so the whole scene when it went on for
like two minutes
um
there was a time
when
something so heavy-handed and on the
nose and corny and cliche ridden
again we you actually get the scene
where the person is holding a cup of
coffee and dramatically drops it
there was a time when something like
that that could only exist in the
Christian movie space
okay though coming from the opposite
ideological perspective but modern
Hollywood has now adopted the same
approach as the Christian film industry
except without the benefit of at least
being right about the issues
if you want to know why Democrats are
about to lose it's because they think
that that what you just watched is an
effective piece of propaganda
when it comes to politics there is
nothing worse than being unintentionally
funny in a political setting you never
want to be that's the worst thing you
could be is unintentionally funny look
at Joe Biden he's unintentionally funny
all the time
because then you've made yourself into a
joke
but that's the Democratic specialty at
this point
and yet it was not all fun and games
also this week NPR did its own bit of
pro-abortion propagandizing while taking
a decidedly different approach
again this is from the daily wire it
says NPR's Michigan Morning Edition
aired in aired in abortion on air
Thursday morning complete with the sound
of the 11 week old pre-born child being
vacuumed from the womb reporter Katie
Wells narrated the account of the
unnamed woman undergoing the abortion at
Northland Family Planning in the Detroit
area quote abortion clinics are almost
always closed to the Press but a group
of Michigan clinics generously allowed
us to embed with them because abortion
rights are on the ballot in Michigan
this November but for the doctors staff
and patients we met there none of this
was about politics Wells wrote in
October during her investigation for the
patients who allowed us into their lives
and their procedures it's about whether
they can escape an abusive partner or
support the kids they already have or
finish school or keep their jobs we're
going to take you inside the clinic she
added for nine days ahead of the midterm
elections Wells shared stories from her
investigation into in a lengthy article
one account spoke of a woman named
Melissa from Ohio who came to Michigan
for an abortion Ohio recently enacted a
ban on most abortions after six week of
pregnancy quote I would be struggling
for a very long time Melissa said I
would have to drop out of school and I
would have to find a different job
because I would need more daycare she
opted to go through with an abortion at
14 weeks of pregnancy
okay so they played the actual audio
of an abortion and I have that clip I'm
not going to play the whole thing
um because I'm you know you have to
decipher yourself if you want to
actually listen to it but
instead we'll play you the the lead up
okay right right up to the moment when
they turn the abortion machine on
uh so I'll play that much at least and
here it is listen
is not one of the patients you heard
before she's asked that we not use her
name she's from Michigan she already has
one kid she
is her abortion at about 11 weeks nearly
all abortions in Michigan are before 13
weeks and like many patients at
Northland she said I could record her
procedure we're going to hear some of
that now so I am just going to get you
set up on the table and we're going to
do that sedation medicine okay I'm gonna
pull this out under your legs most
patients are partially awake during the
procedures they get IV medication for
pain and anxiety the lights are dimmed
they're soothing music it actually feels
a lot like a childbirth the medical gown
your bare legs and stirrups and a person
next to you saying you can do this
[Music]
Brandy she's one of the staffers her job
is to monitor vital signs but it is also
to hold the patient's hand and talk her
through this whether it's a birth or an
abortion it is often women guiding other
women you're going to hear this machine
turn on now okay it makes a loud noise
well that machine is the vacuum that is
used to suck the baby out of the womb
ripping him apart in the process
um the sound of the vacuum is Eerie for
the obvious reasons that it's being used
to murder a child
and also because without that sound the
whole thing would sound very similar to
a childbirth the abortionist urging
haran you know encouraging her saying
keep breathing as she says throughout
the quote procedure at the end um if you
listen all the way to the end you can
hear people in the room laughing and
smiling and saying you did great
this is the point that NPR wants us to
take away that's why they recorded and
aired it in the first place they're
saying see you know abortion isn't scary
it's just like childbirth
except that it's the opposite of
childbirth it is like a satanic parody
of childbirth
to treat the murder of a child as though
it is the birth of a child
that doesn't make the murder better or
more palatable if anything it makes it
worse
if it's possible for it to be worse than
it already is then that would be the
effect here
this should really tell you what you
need to know the NBC and NPR propaganda
given to us in the same week
also gives us a look at at the two ends
of the abortion propaganda Spectrum
there's abortion as portrayed in this
fictionalized universe on NBC and then
there's abortion as it is in reality
which NPR let us listen to
the former the fictionalized version is
inevitably ridiculous and the latter no
matter what they do or how they try to
address it up
it is inevitably horrific and
gut-wrenching
which is why they rarely do this they
rarely give you a look inside when it's
actually happening
and I can tell you that I guarantee NPR
is already regretting their decision
here
you know we're supposed to hear the
sounds of a woman having her baby killed
and think hey that's not so bad
but instead we're viscerally repulsed
and horrified
because there is no appealing or
credible way to present this abortion is
what it is in the end
and what it is is the direct and
intentional murder of innocent human
life
nothing will ever make that okay
the Democrats I think will pay the price
as they should politically
for pinning their electoral hopes on it
now let's get to our five headlines
you know if you've ever been nauseous or
motion sick or dealt with the anxiety
that surrounds being nauseous or motion
sick you know you'll do whatever it
takes to feel normal again that's why
you've got to check out relief band
relief band is the number one FDA
cleared anti-nausea wristband clinically
proven to quickly and effectively
prevent or relieve nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness and
chemotherapy relief band has an A plus
rating with a Better Business Bureau and
over one hundred thousand satisfied
customers whether you need everyday
nausea relief or an occasional cure
relief bands patented technology makes
feeling sick a thing of the past forget
the days of anti-nausea pills that leave
you feeling drowsy Relief pain is
legitimately a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea you
can even change the intensity depending
on how you happen to be feeling uh if
you want the band that actually works to
relieve your nausea check out relief
band I've worked out an exclusive offer
just for my listeners if you've got a
reliefband.com and use promo code Walsh
you'll get 20 off plus free shipping and
a no questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
Walsh for twenty percent off plus free
shipping
from the daily wire we'll uh mention
this right off the top uh it says new
Twitter CEO Elon Musk informed employees
Thursday evening to not come into the
office tomorrow as the company was
laying off a substantial portion of its
Workforce the news comes after Bloomberg
reported earlier this week that musk was
cutting 3 700 of the company's 7 500
employees on Friday so it's cutting
about half of them musk is also
reportedly canceling a work from from
anywhere policy and is going to force
employees to come into the office to
work
what a tyrant they got to come into that
into the office with the Foosball and
and the yoga and meditation and all the
rest of it
um
an email from the company sent all
employees stated in an effort to place
Twitter on a healthy path we will go
through the difficult process of
reducing our Global Workforce on Friday
we recognize that this will impact a
number of individuals who have made
valuable contributions to Twitter but
this action is unfortunately necessary
to ensure the company's success moving
forward given the nature of our
distributed Workforce and our desire to
inform impacted individuals as quickly
as possible Communications for this
process will take place via email the
message said so they're sending out
they're going to find out
um whether they still have jobs or in
fact they're finding out right now I
suppose whether they still have jobs by
via email
uh the emails the email said that
everyone will receive an email about the
future their future at the company
regardless of whether they're being laid
off or not
uh the email said to help ensure the
safety of each employee as well as the
Twitter systems and customer data our
officers will be temporarily closed and
all badge access will be suspended if
you're in an office or on your way to an
office please return home we acknowledge
this is an incredibly challenging
experience to go through whether you're
not whether or not you're impacted thank
you for continuing to adhere to Twitter
Twitter policies uh so on and so forth
so
they said everyone's going to find out
via email and uh if if you're fired then
your email is going to come to your
personal email address and if you're not
then the email will go to your company
email address and that's how they're all
going to find out it is a it's a tough
thing
um
and I'm I'm worried
that Twitter won't be able to function
without
you know 6 000 people in the building
meditating and doing yoga and playing
foosball
I'm concerned about the impact that that
will have
but it is tough I mean Mass layoffs uh
not something you want to see usually
but Twitter brought this on itself this
is its own doing
and it has to happen now
you know Elon Musk today he tweeted this
morning he said
Twitter has had a massive drop in
Revenue due to activist groups
pressuring advertisers even though
nothing has changed with content
moderation and we did everything we
could to appease the activists extremely
messed up they're trying to destroy free
speech in America
well this is exactly the problem though
so Elon Musk says well we did everything
we could to try to appease the activists
and it didn't matter we still lost lost
Revenue
this this is why Twitter's in a spot
that it's in to begin with this is why
they have to make all these cuts
it's because they were appeasing
activists not just appeasing them but
they have a lot of left-wing activists
on staff who are much more concerned
about left-wing activism than they are
about doing their jobs
uh and certainly uh much more concerned
about that than they are about you know
providing a forum for free speech and
all of that
and that's why it concerns me you know
like like I said yesterday
you got to give Elon Musk time I mean I
imagine it's not an easy thing to take
over a multi-billion dollar company and
try to right the ship it's not something
I've ever done or I think I'd be able to
do so you got to give them some time but
you hear things like well we try to
appease the activists well that that's
why you don't appease them
right that's exactly that's exactly
correct you try to appease the activists
and it didn't matter that's why you
don't appease them that's why you ignore
them
there's there's no good that can come of
appeasing the activists and why is that
because they can't be appeased well two
reasons number one their goals
are the opposite of your goals
and so to appease them means that you're
compromising on your own goals for what
is now your company
but then you also can't appease them
anything less than anything uh less than
full capitulation on your part will not
appease them
they get full capitulation they're still
not appeased
you could crawl on the ground groveling
and sobbing and begging for their
approval and their forgiveness and that
will still not appease them
if all you do is try to compromise and
meet them in the middle which is kind of
what Elon Musk seems like right now is
trying to do
by having these two act Twitter content
moderation boards and bringing people in
activists in and having conversations
you sort of try to try to find a middle
ground and meet them in the middle and
talk to them like they're normal
reasonable people but they're not that's
the problem that's why there's no point
even talking to them
hopefully he comes to realize that
let's get into some election in politics
news we've got kind of a grab bag here
so we'll start with this from the daily
wire it says Tennessee election
officials said Wednesday that more than
200 voters cast ballots that have been
cast in the wrong races since early
voting began in Nashville Jeff Roberts
the administrator of the Davidson County
election office told the Associated
Press that 190 voters cast ballots in
the wrong Congressional races 16 cast
votes in incorrect state senate race and
six cast votes in a wrong State House
race the Associated Press notified
Robert's office on Tuesday the voters
were receiving information contradicting
which race they could vote in
the fix has been put in place Robert
said adding that the officials sent
corrections to the Secretary of State's
office on Wednesday and then early
voters would receive the proper ballots
until election day
now this is just a
[Music]
a small preview this is a small
microcosm of the problems that we're
going to see all across the country
and it's why if you're serious about
election Integrity if you're serious
about preserving our democracy uh you
wouldn't have early voting or mail-in
voting none of that with with a few
exceptions active duty military
personnel you make an exception there
that might be like the only exception
that I would make
anything beyond that
you vote in person
on Election Day and that's it in person
on Election Day and also the votes have
to be counted on the same day this is
what nearly every other country with the
democratic system is able to figure out
how to do and yet we can't somehow we
can't figure it out
so we give we give multiple weeks or
months to vote and then multiple days to
count the votes
there's a whole lot that can go wrong
or maybe from the last perspective go
right
during that process
and there's just no excuse for it
there's no reason
if democracy is really this uh this
sacred thing that we must Preserve
that not only would we do everything we
can to ensure its Integrity which starts
by you only vote on one day in person
but also we would have no problem
requiring the people who want to take
part in this sacred rights to to take
time out of their day it's all it's only
one day it's like one day every two
years right
it's like can you one day every two
years this is the day and plan ahead
okay I know how difficult a Candida gets
you know when you've got a job and you
have kids but you got two years notice
plan ahead
get there on on Election Day
I just don't believe that there are
people who would again with a few
exceptions active doing military but
putting those exceptions aside I don't
believe that there are people
who would really really really want to
vote and be and participate in our
democracy
and yet even with two years notice
knowing the exact day when the vote's
gonna happen cannot possibly figure out
a way to carve out you know 30 minutes
or an hour or how whatever however much
time on that day
if it's important to you you'll figure
out how to do it
but I can't because I got this okay well
then it's not that important to you I
guess
you know if you got to use a day off of
work to do it then use the day off and
if you don't you know you don't want to
use the day often if that's fine too you
don't have to
not everybody has to vote
I actually I'm as you know I'm not one
of these people that says it's that we
have a responsibility to vote I don't
think you have a responsibility to vote
I think if you want to vote and and
you're informed and you know what you're
doing
and you're an active participant in
society you're a constructive
participant in society and you're
informed and all that and you really
want to vote then then yes you should
but if it's not that important to you
you're not really paying attention you
don't feel like taking the time off of
work you don't feel like getting a
babysitter whatever
then uh that's for the stone
this is what we would do if we actually
cared about protecting directly but we
don't
moving into the uh
cringe category the fetterman campaign
uh just put out an ad and this is
just like the NBC thing this is uh this
is actually real this is not some kind
of deep fake
they really did this
and
here it is
Mr fetterman yeah you need any help I'm
running for the U.S Senate kid I need
all the help I can get you're on your
first Senate sure
where is your suit in your flagpin and
your hair oh hey kid
I just want you to know I'd vote for you
hey thanks kid you want to drink no no
really you can have it
okay
thanks
[Music]
see you around
[Music]
Hey kid
[Music]
wow thanks Mayor John
it's fine
what's a jack off
um I'll tell you when you're older
okay so that's obviously supposed to be
a play on the The Mean Joe Green
Coca-Cola ad from the 70s or 80s
whenever that was uh it's just like that
ad except that ad did not cause a
potentially fatal case of cringe like
this one does I think I'm brain damaged
now after watching that and the thing is
but yeah I'm watching that and this is
this is circulating a lot on Twitter
this morning so I saw it and people are
giving fetamine a hard time
but actually when I watch it yeah it's
extremely cringy but I was going to say
that that in a certain way I'm impressed
by it because he you know he he's he's
he's stringing together sentences he
appears to be basically
coherent
um and so I'm actually impressed by that
but then as it was playing I was
informed that in fact this is an ad
that's now been picked up in circulating
it's from 2016. so I can't so I can't
even give him credit for that
unfortunately
uh that was that was that was this was
2016. that was fetterman at his Peak
that was Peak fetterman what you just
saw there
and you know what the sad part is
fetterman very well might still win okay
that was Peak fetterman from six years
ago
but now Oz is only ahead in the polls by
a point or two and as you know the polls
are fake no one cares about the polls
but still I'm not actually confident
that Oz wins
um for a couple of reasons one is the
polls but also
you know early voting I think even
before the debate happened there had
been I don't know half a million votes
cast already in the race so this is this
is and this is one of the reasons why uh
they decided to wait to do the debate
they knew they had to do the one debate
they couldn't Dodge it and they knew it
was going to be a disaster and so they
waited until hundreds of thousands of
votes were already were already cast and
then they did
and then they did the uh the debate
um but then also you know Oz is just not
an impressive candidate
this is this is one of the things that's
so frustrating about the Pennsylvania
race is that you're running against a
vegetable a brain dead guy
and almost any Republican you could have
put almost anyone against him so why not
nominate a real conservative if you're
worried about I don't know if a real
conservative can win in Pennsylvania
which I don't think is true
but certainly they they could against
this guy
and instead the Republican voters in
Pennsylvania selected the one Republican
who might actually still lose
and you can blame you know you could
blame the voters of Republican voters in
in Pennsylvania if that happens you
could also blame the people on the right
who endorsed Us in the primaries to
include president Trump
all right while we're on the subject of
cringe uh Camilla Harris was on the
campaign Trail as well raving about Venn
diagrams again watch
and what we are also seeing
is that if you look at you know I like
Venn diagrams okay so if you look I do
and um
if you look at the intersection on some
of these issues it's pretty profound and
very clear
she actually really does like uh Venn
diagrams this is a thing with her she
has this obsession with Venn diagram
it's the it's one of the strangest
political quirks I've ever seen so
here's a I don't know who put this
together but someone someone took the
time she's been talking about Venn
diagrams for years obsessing over them
uh so just watch
remember Venn diagrams those three
circles right and then let's just see
where they overlap you will not be
surprised because I have constructed a
Venn diagram on this remember those
three circles how they overlap I love
Venn diagrams so I just do whenever
you're dealing with conflict pull out a
Venn diagram right and so you know
that's recircles and so uh so I asked my
team right there he sees the Venn
diagram of it all he sees that there are
those circles and maybe people seem that
they're a little different they live in
different parts of the country they may
be different age or different race but
that area in the middle that overlap but
I asked my team to do a Venn diagram of
where these attacks are happening so
voting rights
women's Reproductive Rights lgbtq rights
and of course there was a huge
intersection you know I asked my team to
do a Venn diagram for me of where we are
seeing attacks and who are the attacks
against and the similarity and when you
look at a diagram of the uh just a Venn
diagram in that regard it tells a real
Tale
this is the most bizarre fetish I've
ever heard of
what does it even mean that you love
Venn diagrams that's like saying you
love a bar graph you know it doesn't
depend on what the bar graph shows
I love a chart charts are great
well this chart is showing your approval
ranking tanking Madam vice president oh
but it's a chart though isn't it neat
imagine being on Camilla Harris's staff
every day she demands that you make a
Venn diagram
she doesn't tell you like what she wants
the Venn diagram to say she just wants a
Venn diagram hey you make my daily Venn
diagram
of what what do you what do you mean
what am I what am I putting it just just
give me a Venn diagram
it's very strange uh one more political
ad that I want to show you this one is
garnered outrage on the left and it's
running in Georgia Isaac Hayes III who
I'm pretty sure is the son of Isaac
Hayes the singer posted it with this
capture he says this is a real
commercial running in Georgia racist
co-opting racism that's a new one make
sure you get out and vote Georgia
and here it is
when did racism against white people
become okay Joe Biden put white people
last in line for coveted relief funds
Kamala Harris said disaster Aid should
go to non-white Citizens First liberal
politicians block access to Medicine
based on skin color Progressive
corporations Airlines universities all
openly discriminate against white
Americans racism is always wrong the
left's anti-white bigotry must stop we
are all entitled to equal treatment
under law America First legal paid for
this ad
Co that is co-opting racism or being
told by the left you're co-opting it
uh no every single thing you heard in
that ad is true that is actually
happening
and it's about time they started putting
that in campaign ads
Republicans have been uh have been very
hesitant to talk about you know they'll
they'll dance around it but to actually
name it anti end anti-white bigotry
yeah put that on a poster
like yeah that's that's something to
March that's a that's a banner you can
March under
it's a real thing it's actually
happening
systemic racism against white people
um and and yeah and there are a lot of
white people in this country a lot of
white voters
and there's nothing wrong with letting
them know that hey by the way if you
vote for a Democrat uh you are voting
for bigotry and racism systemic racism
against yourself here are the policies
they support
against you systemically
but on the left they're they're
terrified
that Republicans will actually start
naming this
and galvanizing voters against it
they're terrified of that
they can't really tell you why you
shouldn't
like what's what's wrong if there's if
there's anti-white racism why are we not
allowed to talk about it it's it's
racist to even it's racist to even talk
about anti-white racism
which only proves again how much
anti-white racism there is in this
country
um all right I've had this in the queue
for a few days this is uh from the daily
wire it says the crowd at a Luke Bryant
concert erupted in cheers Friday night
when the country music singer brought
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis on stage
to promote the state's recovery efforts
from Hurricane Ian Brian's concert in
Jacksonville Florida which was part of
his raised up right tour had been
postponed several times in recent weeks
due to the hurricane
Brian said we're going to have some fun
and we're going to raise some money
tonight for the great state of Florida
ladies and gentlemen welcome to Stage
Governor Ron DeSantis and then DeSantis
came out and they were loud cheers and
people were very excited the governor
said all you voters Florida voters if
you want to keep the State of Florida
free we need you to vote on November 8th
and so just a short appearance and uh
and that was it
obviously uh once again the left is very
upset that you know how dare this
country singer bring a republican
governor on on board
Luke Bryan put out a statement a few
days later and this is what a statement
says it's not exactly an apology
but the statement says I typically don't
respond to stuff when I'm getting run
down on a social platform but here's the
deal
I understand Governor DeSantis is a very
polarizing figure but I grew up in a
country where if a governor asks if they
can come and raise awareness to help
victims of a natural disaster you help
I've generally stayed out of politics
throughout my career I knew people would
chatter about this but for me the more
important piece was if I'm going to come
back there a few weeks after a large
portion of people have been affected by
a natural disaster in a state where
people have been good to me this felt
right raise awareness have a little fun
between the Georgia and Florida College
fans before the game and do what I love
on stage this is all I'm saying about
this I'll be outdoors with my boys enjoy
your Sunday love you all go dogs
so not exactly an apology
um
but the the polarizing line is a form of
capitulation
explaining yourself
now I know I talk all the time about
don't apologize
and so you know my speech about that
um
but but to even
you know to even legitimize the
criticisms by explaining yourself in
this way
or sort of um
granting you know granting the premise I
know he's a very polarized polarizing
figure
I wouldn't even do that much
like that's a form of of grovel you're
also explaining yourself to people who
there's there's nothing there's nothing
you can say
that's going to make it okay with them
that's the lesson Elon Musk needs to
learn you're trying to appease people
can't be appeased
meanwhile Stacy Abrams has been brought
out you know at concerts in Georgia and
you think any of those
they pop star to bring Stacy Abrams out
you think they're gonna explain it
you think they're gonna release a
statement saying I know she's a
polarizing figure
no the people critical of Stacey Abrams
being brought on stage they're just
going to be ignored
and so that's the exact same thing you
should do here just ignore them
most these people aren't country fans
anyway they're not Luke Bryan fans so
who cares what they say
all right um
well I can't read any of this article to
you because it's behind a paywall and
I'm not going to pay but here's the
tweet from The Economist with the link
to the article it says in some circles
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine has
called into question not just the value
of reading Russian Masterworks but also
the morality
and the title of the article is yes the
Russian literary canon is Tainted by
imperialism that doesn't mean you should
stop reading it
so I suppose we're supposed to
congratulate the economists for coming
to the right conclusion here that you
don't need to stop reading Russian
novels
um you don't need to hold Tolstoy
accountable for Putin by refusing to
read his work especially because Tolstoy
died like
40 years before Putin was ever born
but entertaining this objection at all
is insane entertaining the idea that you
would refrain from reading some of the
greatest novels of all time because of
imperialism I mean that's what's
ridiculous Russian literature is Tainted
by imperialism yeah do you know which
which other great works of literature
were written by people who lived in an
Empire or who believed in what we call
imperialism or who at least had views on
the subject that don't line up with
modern mainstream leftism you know how
many like I don't know 80 of all of all
the great books in history
or maybe more maybe 100 certainly 100 of
the great novels were written by people
who whether on the subject of
imperialism or on other subjects had
views that the modern left would find
objectionable that is 100 of of the
great authors in history
that's 100 of the great people in
history
which is why you don't you don't um
you don't hold them up to that standard
it's absurd to do so
a lot of great authors too were were you
know troubled
people Dostoevsky was not he would not
have been a pleasant guy to be around
a lot a lot of interesting facts about
his life
but if you're gonna let that stop you
from Reading crime and punishment or
from Reading uh you know
um uh Brothers K or one of his great
books then that's you know that's you're
you're punishing yourself
and if people want to punish themselves
by saying oh I can't I can't read this
literature
because I don't approve of it well if
you want to punish yourself in that way
that's fine you're going to be a less
interesting person reading great works
of literature makes you a more
interesting well-rounded intelligent
person so you are making yourself less
interesting and less intelligent you can
do that I have no problem with that
that's your choice
uh the issue is when this makes its way
into the school system
you're making this choice for kids
which of course is the next step
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
while today's coffee often comes with
hints of soy and social justice Black
Rifle coffee delivers an entirely
different experience bold strong and
delicious Black Rifle coffee is the
coffee I choose to get me through the
day Black Rifle coffee is veteran
founded and operated their mission is to
help service members successfully
transition from the military into
entrepreneurship they provide assistance
to Veterans who seek to launch
businesses of their own with the goal of
helping more companies like Black Rifle
become a reality Black Rifle is
committed to hiring 10 000 veterans and
they're well on their way as for the
coffee itself Black Rifle is very
selective about where they Source their
coffee beans and very disciplined when
it comes to ensuring the freshness of
every bag so all you got to do is go to
blackrightfulcoffee.com use promo code
Walsh for 10 off your first order or
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription the subscription gives you
free shipping on all coffee Club orders
Early Access to Club deals and
promotions and special discounts from
their partner Brands that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code Walsh
for 10 off your first order or when you
sign up to become a coffee Club member
Black Rifle coffee supporting veterans
and America's coffee
Johnny The Walrus says I'd love to see
Matt going through security alone at the
airport and the TSA searches his bag and
sees a stuffed bearded baby well that's
uh no we checked those bad the bags with
that kind of paraphernalia I don't even
know if that's legal on a plane or not
so we checked those
uh that's uh you know that's I don't
want to test the TSA policies on that
Jamie Jones says Dwayne my son now has
17 cavities and horrible nausea and
vomiting because he wanted to eat all of
his Halloween candy at once as a good
parent I followed his lead I'll be
sending you the medical and dental bills
as you are such a good dad and generous
person I'm sure you're more than happy
to cover it well remember what what
Dwyane Wade said is that our job what
was the exact phrasing our job as a
parent is to
it's to sit back
and see where our kids want to go and
just go there with them
so yeah your kid wants to go into the
Halloween bag and eat all of the candy
all at once and so your job is to it's
to accompany them on on that Journey
be a supportive and affirming voice
Anthony said Matt thanks for covering
the story about the priest and Carrie
you should hear what the media are
saying about it over here half the time
they're saying that they want separation
of church and state but now all the
government reps are weighing in and
saying he should apologize so separation
only when it suits them another similar
comment from the Dublin kitchen
hi Matt I live in Dublin Ireland it
wasn't just the bishop that threw that
priest under the bus over the last few
days that priest has been on mainstream
media shows and they more or less tried
to make him look stupid at least or
insane
um the the the Irish media has moved so
much to the left it's hard to watch or
even listen to it anymore
and this is all remember what they
always what they what what we were told
by the left
for so many years they said
you know your religious views
don't don't say them out in public keep
that that's where the church is for but
put you know go to church if you want to
be religious I don't want to see your
crosses and all the all that kind of
stuff here uh just go to church you know
church is where is what religion is for
and of course in the United States we
have the First Amendment and that that
was never an accurate reflection of what
the first amendment guarantees you know
you are allowed to uh express your
religious views anywhere that's what
that's what the first amendment
guarantees
but even so but what do we find out that
actually no they don't even want you to
talk about this in church
uh do you do all this talk all this
Christian nonsense in church well then
then you go to church and uh if a priest
actually dares to express or teach
Christian values this is what happens to
them
so it was all scam all along
um Brian says hey Matt I really
appreciated your commentary on men being
called to fatherhood I'm currently in my
mid-30s and have been taking care of my
handicapped father for the last four
years of my life it's been hard to find
a balance a love life on top of that and
improve my career but a big part of my
nieces and nephews lives and I'm close
with my community I've coached little
league and my little league teams in my
community and strive to be a positive
member of the community even if I'm
never able to have kids of my own I'll
always be called to some level of
fatherhood and I think that's what
you're saying thanks again keep up the
good work well that is exactly what I'm
saying most most men are called
to biological fatherhood to you know to
actually uh conceiving and raising kids
but not all men
and you know the other thing is that
there are men who are called to have to
biological fatherhood will call it
um and fulfill the first part of the
calling which is conceiving the children
but then not the rest of it and then
they just abandon their kids
and what that means is that uh in a lot
of communities you've got a lot of a lot
of young kids young men
who don't have the male role models and
that's where someone like yourself you
know as a as a coach as a as a role
model mentor
you know you can be you can you can be
that male role model and that's um that
uh uh example to those to those kids so
that is certainly you know that
it's not to say that you'll never get
married and have kids of your own but
you know maybe this is your this this
will end up being ultimately your
vocation and it's a quite a noble
vocation
and it's still it is still a paternal
vocation
uh
let's see
Matthew Kelly says Matt Walsh
complaining about people wanting to see
themselves in McDonald's toy while a
literal plush toy with his face on it
sits right behind him
is hilarious
and now you think he might have a gotcha
here with that
but the difference is I don't want to
see myself that way and I didn't I don't
get it you think I have a choice in any
of this you think they ask me
no they just they just one day say hey
we got we made you into a baby doll toy
and we're gonna sell your likeness
and profit off of it
they just tell me that
so no I don't I don't want to see myself
that way but it just it just it just is
it happens
and then when they tell me and I object
to it and I say I disagree with this in
principle and they say well we're doing
it
and then I say okay fine I just want to
cover the profits and that is that's
principle okay that's how I stand that's
the kind of man I am
as you all know flannel Friday is a
special day for the sweet baby gang it's
a reminder of episodes gone by hundreds
of hours of carefully haunted commentary
all wrapped in a plaid package by
signature flannels now only visible on
Fridays or on the road where the
Wardrobe Department can't reach me are a
sign of comfort and familiarity to all
my sweet babies you may even be wearing
a flannel right now but think about how
much more flannel you could be wearing
now stop thinking because the flannel
Friday patch is still available in my
swag Shack add it to your favorite
flannel your skin or wherever whatever
whatever Place best demonstrates your
level of commitment to the sweet baby
game The Last patch sold out fast so
don't wait go to dailywire.com shop to
add to your patch collection and also
flannel Arsenal also Christmas is
usually December 25th but this year it's
coming early because not only is a red
wave going to wash over this country and
save it from the tyrannical left there's
also a ton of new daily wire plus
content for you to enjoy starting with
episode two of Jordan Peterson's new
series on marriage uh this episode is
all about negotiating or I should say
learning the proper way to negotiate
Candace Owens also has a brand new
episode of her new show taboo featuring
special guests and multi-platinum
selling musician M.I.A you'll hear about
her rise to fame and being canceled for
speaking out about vaccine mandates then
there's Ben Shapiro Sunday special
releasing this Sunday Ben sat down with
uh Tennessee governor Bill Lee to chat
about school choice fighting through
coveted policies his experience on a
woman's health clinic board and much
more last up daily wire plus is now
streaming the documentary film my dinner
with Trump which gives us a behind the
curtain look at the former president and
his closest advisors as they dine
together does private club at
bedminister regardless of how you may
feel about the man this is truly Donald
Trump as the media would never show you
and certainly nothing like this exists
or has ever existed on the right so yes
it's a huge week here and if you're not
yet a member there's never been a better
time to join go to dailywire.com Walsh
to become a member today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
the World Series is apparently happening
this week or already happened there's no
way to know for sure all we know is that
the racial Bean counters are on the job
on the lookout and the Associated Press
has this report quote looking around
Memorial Stadium before game one of the
1983 World Series Philadelphia Phillies
star Gary Matthews saw a lot of Black
Talent Joe Morgan Eddie Murray Gary
Maddox Ken Singleton Al bumbry Disco Dan
Ford and plenty more that night in
Baltimore there were quite a few of us
Matthews recalled when fans watched the
Houston Astros and Phillies lineup this
week to begin the fall classic it'll be
a much different picture to be sure
Houston's Jose Altuve and Philadelphia's
Jean Segura Gene Segura I don't know
yeah that's probably Gene Jean
I just made them French Jean segora are
among scorers of Latin players uh
helping keep Big League rosters diverse
but for the first time since 1950
shortly after Jackie Robinson broke the
Major League Baseball color barrier
their project to be uh their project to
be no U.S born so this is no U.S born
black players in this world series zero
quote that is eye-opening said BoB
Kendrick president of the Negro League's
baseball stadium in Kansas City Missouri
quoted somewhat is startling that two
cities that have high African-American
populations that there wouldn't be a
single black player it lets us know
there's obviously a lot of work to be
done to create opportunities for black
kids to pursue their dream at the
highest level he said Robinson debuted
in 1947 with the Brooklyn Dodgers and
played in the World Series that year
since then the 1950 matchup between the
New York Yankees and Phillies has been
the only World Series without a black
player
okay so there are no black players
scratch that there are no U.S born black
players
so you can mark this down as the first
time the left-wing media has ever
advocated for U.S born people you will
never hear them lament the absence of
U.S born citizens in any context
unless they found some strange way to
fit it into their racial grievance
narrative as they have here
and and if there is a racial grievance
however ridiculous and Petty it may be
to be found in the Sports World you can
guarantee that Stephen A Smith will be
following close behind indeed the more
ridiculous and Petty the better as far
as he's concerned and so here's what he
had to say
we are still black in this country we
don't trust this country in terms of
meritocracy always we know the bottom
line is that just like women are
underpaid compared to male counterparts
blacks are underpaid compared to White
counterparts and so when you look at it
from that perspective and of course I
have people look at me I'm not talking
about me even though I got news for you
I am underpaid compared to some people
on television and what they get paid but
that's the subject for another day I
ain't apologizing for that to a damn so
I am underpaid having said all of that
it ain't about me
I just made it about me but it's not
about me let me talk about myself but
this isn't about me Smith is underpaid
he says he makes 12 million dollars a
year and is one of the highest paid
broadcasters of the world he has managed
to pull in that salary despite the fact
that it's physically impossible to
listen to him for more than 45 seconds
without developing a debilitating
migraine he has never made an insightful
point in his entire career not one
person on Earth has ever said this
phrase
you know Stephen A Smith made a really
good point today
no one's ever said that ever that is a
statement that has never been uttered by
human lips and yet he's made a million
dollars a month he makes more in a month
than the average American will make in
like 20 years and he's underpaid and
he's the victim of racism
never mind that his most recent white
co-host Max Kellerman made a fraction of
his salary you know but these details
are Irrelevant for some reason
yeah we shouldn't let this this
stupidity distract us
from the stupidity that was meant to be
the subject of our daily cancellation
which is the claim that a lack of U.S
born black players in the world series
is a symptom of racism
notice how the game is played here like
every roster in the NFL is majority
black but there's still racism because
there's not enough coaches who are black
the World Series has minority players
Major League Baseball in general has
tons of minority players but there's
still racism because there aren't enough
of them born in the United States
Houston's manager is also black that
doesn't count because he's not a player
so the NFL is racist because there are
black players but not enough black
coaches the World Series is racist
because there are black coaches but not
enough black players
it's almost like everything is racist
literally no matter what
by the way here's the Astros manager
Dusty Baker who again is black
talking about this issue listen
something
you know is it could they be proud of
you know because it's a it looks bad it
lets people know that
you know uh
it didn't take
uh
a year or even a decade to get to this
point but there is help on the way
you can tell by the number and uh
African-American number one draft
choices
the academies are producing
players so hopefully in the near future
we won't have to talk about this anymore
or even be in this situation
in the future maybe we won't have to
talk about it anymore we don't talk
about it now
he says it looks bad so so which of his
white players should be replaced by a
black player does he have players on his
team who don't deserve to be there
whose fault is that if so
is this what systemic racism looks like
what kind of systemically racist system
in the NFL would welcome hundreds of
black players and pay them millions of
dollars what kind of systemically racist
system in the MLB would welcome tons of
foreign-born non-white players and pay
them millions of dollars
is this how systemic racism works now
is there actually evidence of U.S born
blacks being denied from baseball
roster's rosters because of the color of
their skin and the and their origin of
birth
isn't it simply true that black kids in
America are less likely to end up
playing baseball because they're much
more likely to end up playing basketball
or football
isn't that a result of choice not racism
and if lack of opportunity does factor
in isn't it that merely you know a
function of the fact that black people
are more likely than whites to live in
urban environments where baseball fields
are more scarce because they take up
more space and basketball hoops are more
common
what does it even mean to say that more
black people should be playing baseball
don't the black people themselves have a
say in this
which of the non-baseball playing Black
Americans should be playing baseball
right now
should we like assign it to them should
we force them into it in order to
balance the racial baseball scale
anytime somebody laments a lack of X
group in y profession what they're
really saying is that a certain portion
of the members in that group who are not
in that profession should be in it
but what does that mean
I mean how can you make a statement like
that if you start guiding more black
kids into baseball you're also guiding
them away from whatever else they might
do
one other point we're told that we need
to increase black representation in
basically every profession from Sports
to medicine to engineering and so on
but black people are a minority in this
country you really can't dramatically
increase the representation in every
possible profession
there's just aren't enough people to go
around
unless of course you also increase the
number of black people born in the U.S
but the left doesn't want to do that
because they're too busy killing
millions of black people in the womb
but these points are all academic I mean
the race Hustlers don't care about any
of it they'll find racism under every
Rock and in every nook and cranny
they'll find it one way or another
because the victim narrative must stay
alive no matter what
and that is why Stephen A Smith and the
Associated Press both repeat customers
repeat offenders I should say are today
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to our members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday have a great weekend
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]